what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the
epic battle between the number five pro
hero
miroko and no less than four insanely
overpowered high-end nomu who were
created by ujico for the explicit
purpose
of annihilating heroes in my mind miruko
just shot
way up on the list of the most badass
female
animated manga characters of all time
and in this latest battle miracle's
confidence and unstoppable spirit
gave me strong mere leona vibes if you
know me then you know how much i
love mario leona from black clover and i
think that mirko deserves to be
mentioned
in the same breath as the uncrowned
undefeated lioness
but it's not all good news a tragic
twist
has just occurred and more tragedy could
be on the way
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
book no hero
content right here on the channel and
you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and or instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will contain boku no
hero manga spoilers
i am talking about the latest
developments in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned as the number six pro hero crust
and several
other heroes face off against that same
high-end nomu that had recognized crust
by name
this nomu reveals that it is able to
swell its body
into a giant ball and the nomu tries to
use its body to block the heroes from
entering the secret lab crust is
determined to break through
in order to help miruko who is facing
off against the four
other high end nomu on her own crust's
quirk is finally revealed
as the shield hero he has the ability to
create strong shields across his whole
body
and he tries to push the engorged nomu
back by using two large shields that are
popping out of his forearms
as crust continues to face off against
the nomu
we the readers get some additional
information about
nomu the nomu are actually corpses that
are modified so that they can take on
multiple quirks the nomu are split into
three different categories
low tier mid tier and high tier the
tiers depend on the nommo's strength
and the amount of quirks that the nomu
actually possesses
even the weakest high tier nomu are 10
times as strong as a normal human
and the highest of the high and normal
have even greater strength and they also
have the ability to think on their own
and they retain their original
personalities most of them also appear
to be able to speak
relatively coherently unlike the lower
end nomu
in order to create the best high-end
nomus the doctor specifically selected
villains who had the most suitable
personality
and combat capability in order to
artificially transplant a quirk
into another body an intense time
consuming surgery is required followed
by over three months of stabilization
time
ujico cannot create many of them at once
without the help of all for one
presumably all for one's ability to
steal quirks and transfer them onto
another person makes the entire process
much faster and easier ujiko is visibly
upset that he had to force these
five high and no moon to awaken before
they have been properly tested
and he's also upset that he lost johnny
and mokachan
poor johnny we'll never forget you
little buddy
it is then revealed that shigaraki is
currently at 71
stabilization rate judging by all the
information that we received up to this
point
it seems that shigaraki's procedure is
meant to transfer a new quirk or
quirks into his body in the same way
that new quirks were transferred
into the nomu but of course we know that
shigaraki is not a corpse
so this is presumably an even more
delicate procedure
fujiko is aware that their escape route
has been compromised
and while dahai and nomu are buying him
some time it doesn't look like shigaraki
will reach anywhere close to 100
stabilization rate before the heroes
reached them
so the question is what will fujiko do
now is he going to try to somehow escape
with shigaraki still
inside the tube or is he going to have
to release shigaraki from the tube
prematurely since ujico doesn't seem to
have an escape route in mind
it is possible that he intends to
release shigaraki before he is ready
although it will kill him to do it ujiko
is a lifelong scientist and he considers
shigaraki's procedure to be his
masterpiece
so having to cut it short now and risk
everything
after all the things that he has done to
get to this point must be
killing him but that still leaves us
with the following question
what will happen to shigaraki if he is
forced to emerge from the tube
prematurely is he going to collapse
unable to function properly
is he going to be functioning normally
but he just won't be as strong as he
would have been if he had completed the
procedure
or is he going to be extremely strong
but unable to control himself
so basically an overpowered berserk mode
shigaraki who doesn't have his normal
personality and is just a mindless
machine of destruction
i think that this is the key question
moving forward
what will happen to shigaraki now and
will his release from the tube
be a game changer for the story if
shigaraki emerges stronger than he was
before
and if he is able to function and fight
normally without falling apart or
collapsing or something along those
lines
then the heroes are looking at a deadly
fight against a top-tier
overpowered villain the likes of which
they've never seen before
but as tragic as ujic's failure to
complete his masterpiece is
and i'm sure that every mad scientist
out there can relate to ujico's pain
that was not the tragedy that i was
referring to in the title of this video
the chapter then takes us back to the
undisputed bunny queen
miroko who is still alive despite the
massive onslaught by four high-end
nomu instead of worrying about the nomu
miruko is completely focused on dr ujiko
and how to get him and stop him from
causing any more damage
miraculous quirk is of course being able
to do pretty much anything that a rabbit
can do
but the way that she uses her quirk is
absolutely amazing
for instance she was able to offset the
damage caused by the impact of the
nomu's attack with her legs
and she is then able to run and hop
circles around the nomu
kicking and smashing them all over the
secret lab
throughout the entire fight mirko was
completely
focused on her mission which is to find
and stop
fujiko and she doesn't allow fear doubt
or distraction of any kind to cloud her
judgment
at any point mirko's performance
throughout this
fight is absolutely incredible and
extremely impressive
during their fight against miroko we got
to see the first
real glimpse into the quirks that these
four high-end nomu possess
the one who kind of looks like super boo
is able to extend his hair
tube thing and turn it into a bunch of
long tentacles that it uses to try to
restrain miruko
the one with long hair and breasts is
seemingly able to turn parts of its body
into liquid and the one with the long
nose
seems to have elephant-esque powers so
we can assume that it has
amazing strength and other powerful
abilities although we don't really see
him in action that much
the nomu with the super boo hairdo is
also able to grow
deadly spikes on its back and possibly
all over its body
and the nomu who's face looks like a
mecha from neon genesis evangelion
is able to launch some kind of swirly
weapon that succeeds in
cutting off part of miroko's left arm
but this tragic loss of her arm doesn't
seem to bother
miroko at all she jumps on top of the
mechanomu
grabs his head in between her legs and
just as the nomu tries to use some kind
of eye laser quirk on miroko she uses
her super thick thighs
to rip the nomu's head clean off
damn but what a way to go this
seems to take the mechanomu out for good
and miroko concludes that if she only
has to crush the heads of the nomu in
order to defeat them then this will be
even easier than fighting a normal
villain
because unlike with a normal villain she
doesn't have to hold back
oh and did i forget to mention that
miroko also casually uses her own hair
as a tourniquet for her mangled arm in
order to stop her own bleeding during
the fight
if that isn't the epitome of badassery
i don't know what is the absolutely
fierce
and fearless miracle declares that she
constantly lives with the reminder that
she could die
any day so that when she does die she
will have
no regrets she proclaims that the hero
miroko will not
be taken down by some mindless zombies
what an epic philosophy for a hero or
any person to have
and i can't help falling in love with
miracle as a character with
each passing chapter what an absolute
mad lass this whole miracle fight gave
me some serious
meroleona from black clover vibes and i
absolutely love
mera leona she's one of my favorite
characters in black
clover miruko's fight with the four
high-end nomu reminds me of mario
leona's fight against the five
elves and miroko's incredible skill
power
confidence and unflinching resolve in
the face of op
opponents and grave injuries really puts
her right up there with marielaona when
it comes to
awesomeness despite being a fairly new
character in the story
miroko has already cemented her status
as one of the most
badass female characters in manga
and while it is definitely a tragedy
that she lost part of her arm
during this fight her unflinching
resolve and courage
are truly inspirational despite losing
part of her arm she just kept
fighting like nothing happened she just
continues to face off against a bunch of
high-end nomu
on her own using her own hair as a
tourniquet
so far she has seemingly taken out two
of the nomu
already and although they may come back
to life as a result of some mysterious
quirk or power
no matter what happens miroko has
already hopped her way into my top
5 boku no hero characters and i really
hope that she actually survives
this battle i fear that once shigaraki
is released he will prove to be too much
for miroko
but i really hope that she does survive
even if she ends up being severely
injured by the end of it come on
recovery girl
do your magic please also if we really
need to lose a top tier hero during this
battle
please make it crust nothing personal
crust but
miruko is miroko guys definitely let me
know what you thought about miroko in
this fight
did you love her as much as i did and
did she just hop her way into all of
your hearts
as she did into mine hit me up down in
the comments below
not to mention that as all of this is
happening inside the secret lab at the
hospital
the action suddenly switches to the
paranormal liberation front mansion
we see skeptic running and screaming
clearly panicked about something
he says that twice screwed up and now
they're all screwed
skeptic says that after the conversation
between hawks and twice
he had kept a close eye on hawks but
there wasn't even a hint
of strange behavior this scene seems to
reveal that the liberation front
really did suspect hawks of being a spy
but apparently
even after receiving that valuable intel
from twice
hawks was able to keep the liberation
front fooled until the very last moment
as skeptic screams that the heroes are
coming someone from the outside
seemingly slices the entire wall of the
mansion
in half wow as if the battle against the
nomu at the hospital wasn't hype enough
but the second battlefront at the
mansion has now officially
opened up and it's about to go down over
there as well
by the way which hero do you think did
that sudden and massive damage to the
mansion wall
let me know down below i said it before
and i'll say it again
i'm loving this massive war arc in mha
and i can't wait to see what happens
next i hope you guys feel the same way
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more please leave a like to let
me know
it really does help and if you happen to
be new to anime outpour or you just
haven't subscribed yet
please don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and or instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime outpour patrons for supporting
our work and making these videos
possible with all the constant problems
on youtube patreon support is more
important than ever
thank you guys so much first and
foremost a special thank you to our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all
other clans including ingrata alolan
adam
the world steelers the school bus tyson
quirino a quiet respect
and pate heffa and i can't forget our
pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan
jason wilson king zeldras 50 dollar beat
alpha dio anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
team sparky65 cricket xp rohan kapoor
jessica maloney emperor otaku timothy e
vargas
sean dark joe stanton jcc walker
very gucci and jessica k levong
if you enjoy our videos and you think
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you